in this lesson we're going to talk about
systems of equations now in the act this
is an important concept to understand
and there's a few different ways to
solve these systems of equations you can
graph them and find out where the two
lines intersect
or you can use the substitution or
elimination method so let's look at a
couple examples here together and then
we'll get into some of the word problems
as you would likely see them on the ect
so this first example here is really set
up nicely to use the substitution method
so how do we do the substitution method
well we solve for one of the variables
in this case we know what y equals it's
3x plus 1 and what we can do is we can
substitute just like a substitute
teacher you can swap that out with your
normal teacher and
put that in place of y here so we have
2x minus and notice i'm putting that in
parentheses that whole quantity is being
subtracted
equals negative 4. now we just have one
equation with x in it that's going to be
easy to solve so first thing i'm going
to do is i'm going to distribute the
negative so we get 2x minus 3x minus 1
equals negative four
and then that's going to give us
negative x minus one equals negative
four add one to the other side that
gives us negative x equals negative
three and you can see that uh by
multiplying both sides by negative one x
is three
now how do we solve for y well you can
take that x value and put it either in
here or in here either one and solve for
y you're going to get the correct answer
the same answer but it's going to be
easier to put into this one because we
already have y by itself so if we put 3
in here we get y equals three
times three plus one so that means y
equals ten so three comma ten
is the point where the two lines are
going to cross or intersect now if it's
a multiple choice question sometimes
you're just better off and it's easier
and quicker just to take those solutions
a b c d
and go ahead and put them in and see
which ones are going to make both
equations true now you want to make sure
it doesn't just make one of them true it
has to make them both true then you know
that's the common point of intersection
so you can work backwards in that manner
i'm just showing you how to do the
substitution method just the algebraic
method okay now another approach to
these problems is to do the elimination
method and this is handy when both of
the variables are on the left the
numbers are on the right x's and y's are
lined up and what you want to do is you
want to add these equations together or
subtract these equations in such a way
that either the y's cancel out or the
x's cancel out sometimes what you'll
have to do is you'll have to multiply
one of the equations by a constant maybe
let's say by let's say if i wanted to
eliminate x's here i'd have to multiply
this by negative 2 negative 2 negative
2. so when i add those the x's would
cancel out but in this case i can see
i've got negative y and positive y i
could just add them as they are right
now and the y's are going to cancel so
2x plus 1x is 3x
the y's cancel we get 8 plus 7 is 15.
divide both sides by 3
x is 5. if i put 5 back into here or
here i can solve for y i'm just going to
put it into this bottom equation
five plus y equals seven subtract five
from both sides y equals two so the
answer is going to be five comma two now
again if i want to check my answer just
put five and two in for x and y in both
equations as long as it makes them both
true you know you got the right answer
okay so let's get into some of the more
uh
likely forms of the system of equation
problems as you would see them on the
act so go ahead and pause the video see
if you can do these problems on your own
we'll go through them together
i'll read it here for you if you have
two dollars and you save ten dollars per
week and your brother has sixty dollars
and saves twelve dollars per week and
how many weeks we have the same amount
okay so we wanna do is we wanna write
two equations and the way we would do
that is we'll just use the slope
intercept form of the line y equals mx
plus b y represents how much you've
saved
b represents the amount that you have
currently that's the initial condition
and the and the slope that's the rate at
which you're saving so here we have
let's see
let's see you've got y equals
10 x plus
72 that's for you and your brother would
be let's see y equals 12x plus 60. so he
already has 60 that's his initial
condition and his rate of saving as 12
dollars per week now we're trying to
solve for x the number of weeks at which
point you'll both have the same amount
this one's a good one to do substitution
we know what y equals let's just put
that in place of y there and so now what
we have is 10x plus 72 equals 12x plus
60.
i'm going to subtract 10x from both
sides
so that gives us 2x plus 60 equals 72.
i'm going to subtract 60 from both sides
so that's 12 equals 2x and divide both
sides by 2 and you can see x equals 6 so
in 6 weeks you'll have the same amount
okay example 2 it says if 3x plus 5y
equals 13 and 2x minus 4y equals
negative 6 what is the value of x plus
3y
so see if you can do this one on your
own and we'll do it together i'm just
going to write it down here 3x plus 5y
equals
let's see 13 right
and we've got 2x minus 4y equals
negative 6.
okay so in this case here what i'm going
to do is i'm going to try to eliminate
the the x's and i'm going to do that by
multiplying the top equation by negative
2 and the bottom equation by 3. now why
am i doing that well negative 2 times 3
is negative 6x 3 times 2 gives you
positive 6x this way when we add those
together the x's are going to cancel out
and we can solve for y
so let me go ahead and do that i'm going
to distribute the negative 2 to
everything here and that's going to give
us negative 6x
right
minus 10y
equals negative 26. and if we multiply
here everything by 3 we get let's see
positive 6x
minus 12y
equals
negative 18. okay so when we add you can
see the x's cancel we get negative 22 y
equals
negative 44 divided by negative 22 and
you can see that y equals 2.
all we have to do now is put the 2 back
into any one of these equations for y
and solve for x i'm just going to put it
into the top equation so that's 3x plus
5 times 2 equals 13.
3x plus 10 equals 13. subtract 10 from
both sides 3x equals 3 divide by 3 and
you can see that x equals 1 so our
solution is 1 comma 2
and again if you want to see if that's
the right answer you can just put 1 and
2 in you know and make sure that you get
13
and also negative 6. but now we have to
take this one step further it says
what's the value of x plus 3y
well that's going to be 1 plus 3 times 2
so that's 6 plus 1 equals 7. so your
final answer is going to be 7. they just
added on an extra step here
once we found the solution we had to
just substitute those values in so again
substitution elimination and solving
systems of equations is an important
concept to understand for the act